ahora está presente en decenas de países
y se está extendiendo a gran velocidad
la variante Omicron detectada por
primera vez a mediados de noviembre en
Sudáfrica tiene al mundo entero
preocupado aunque hasta ahora no ha sido
mortal los científicos coinciden en que
es muy contagiosa y según muchos de
ellos la única solución es la vacunación
aumentar la producción de las vacunas
que ya tienen otra es hacer por ejemplo
una bivalente en la que se tiene una
vacuna contra la cepa ancestral y la
nueva variante y la última es hacer un
refuerzo específico para la variante
ya es dominante y el director gerente
del FMI advertido de que es probable que
se produzca un aumento del crecimiento
mundial